I just found out this thing about Jon
Hamm that I guess was kind of buried for
a long time which is that don't say
anything that was
I love him I'm the biggest madman fan
ever he's a nice guy
um and I know again he was he's like my
top five right I was in a movie what
movie
but nobody watches but it's out there
anyway so I want to say it like
apparently he got into a lot of trouble
in college because he dragged a man by
his testicles with other end of a hammer
in like some hazing incident okay
yeah oh he's from Missouri I mean that's
like the last that's the least biggest
crime in that [__] state right that's
true yeah yeah but yeah like he was he
hazed this guy who like he beat to a
pulp and like completely like
and [__] him up and he's still down
like he's got like and he got marks on
his testicles this guy yeah but you know
this part of the hammer yeah I know what
the other end yeah he dragged him by his
nuts in some like hazing thing and this
was all like well documented this was
like a thing he got arrested for it and
everything that's how we got the part in
the show like we heard you're a Madman
it makes sense yeah wow allegedly that's
why I don't go those caught like I
wouldn't have never gotten a fraternity
um oh my God it was no you're not a guy
zero appeal [__] you have Haze
energy no he loves to Haze no but he's
been hazing George for 10 years
what's hazing mean then I think you like
you're like you know kind of dictator
Vibe no it's a defense mechanism my
personality okay it's because the world
around me is so hostile I have to
protect myself
yeah you know what I mean because you
you have jock energy dude you have bully
jock energy in order to defend myself
yeah he got robbed drugged and robbed in
Colombia oh that's right you got drugged
by dragon's breath damn his hair says
white nationalist
so his face says uh GameStop
I mean that's true you have two things
going on like in high school were you a
nerd or were you a jockey I was kind of
neither I went to a small school in the
city so it was like not our sport sucked
anyway so no no kid on the on this team
was like get out of my way loser I was
like you suck too yeah you know so no I
I mean I play basketball but our team
sucked yeah so but you were on the team
yeah but we oh you want to know how
[__] bad we were I remember they were
like we were scrimmaging against a deaf
school and I'm like are we this bad by
the way the deaf kids don't hear the
whistles so they just beat the [__] out
of you wow they like really play up the
whole death thing when I'm like you guys
could dial it back a little you know I
remember I went up for a dunk against
one of them and he just yanked my hand
down and I hit my head and got a
concussion and yeah and they were just
like whatever and I was like these
[__] deaf kids are mean wow yeah
really they're aggressive in that way it
was like a game that just didn't count
it was just like well you just play a
deaf school right I was like all right
is there a blind team I don't think we'd
beat them either I think they would oh I
think I could beat a blind team yeah
probably you ever play basketball I've
made two hoops
in my life what from where from what the
three-point line no just I've probably
thrown 300 throws I only made it in
twice oh wow like that what's that game
horsey what's it called you've said
every word wrong
made two throws
I mean this is terrible
no I you know horsey horse yeah we go H
you know how it works okay yeah you do
yeah yeah yeah and um I've I've never
won that game
I would love to see you you would laugh
and you would shame me and I wouldn't
not who shames anyone at home this guy
would now you wouldn't laugh I would
laugh I would shame you okay you're a
comedian it's funny yeah I would never
play horse with you really you and I
will never do anything like that tennis
I suck at tennis okay damn it are you
good I'm okay yeah yeah he's good he's
good at hockey tennis ping pong ping
ping pong and wrestling I could have
guessed ping pong he's gonna swing he's
a good swimmer yeah are you I'm okay
yeah yeah yeah I mean not like you know
Olympic style right
I would go to the rec center back in the
day and I would go there a lot because
it was 150 bucks for the year it's crazy
you just swim laps but those pools are
so a lot of Asians by the way a lot of
Asian people but there's always like
these weird uh the lanes are overcrowded
so you have to swim around people
there's like a fat lady on a noodle who
would go there and you'd have to swim
around it they'd just float it's a mess
but would you have to wait your turn or
because there are so many people no
you're just gonna swim around people's
circles you do yeah and that was you can
do that in the winter time yeah whoa
it's pretty cool 150 for a year and you
get access to a pool in New in New York
that's a good deal so you grew up um in
Manhattan yeah with my yeah my dad did
pretty well he's a lawyer yeah these are
good yeah so you had a good opera game
it was pretty good I didn't I had a
complicated upbringing my dad who raised
me is amazing my other dad sucked your
stepdad my stepdad's who raised me he's
great he's a lawyer yeah he's a great
guy you